There is out there an appetite against political correctness...
...which is what you have described?
In fact, your YouTube videos are called Professor Against Political Correctness.
But let's make sure we're all speaking the same language here.
You would define that how, political correctness?
Well I think it's a particular kind of ideological game.
And I think the outcome is twofold.
It's to make the player feel morally superior.
And also to take rather serious axe swings at the foundation of society.
And so the game is identify a domain of human endeavor,...
...note that there's a distribution of success.
Some people are doing comparatively better...
...and some people are getting comparatively worse.
Define those doing worse as victims.
Define those doing better as perpetrators.
Identify with the victims.
Have yourself a set of enemies handy to vent your resentment on.
Feel good about it even though it didn't really require any work on your part.
And then endlessly repeat.
And that's why I've seen that happening on campuses in particular...
...for the last thirty years.